hallo ich mit ihm freuen und herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge trouble in meinen wir immer noch
zusammen mit simon und gommel hd hallo
hallo ich heiße luft und kommt
vielleicht simon falls ihm ein kanal so
sehr schöner name übel sind jetzt auf
dem gleichen server wir sehr viel
erreichen scheiße einfach nic nick also
ich habe und wie ich heiße thompson 32
ich hab so einen anzug an und vollendete
kopf da ist ich habe so eine technik zu
häufig oder hast du für mich noch immer
einen guten namen übrig red josi motto
sy motto sy groß geschrieben dass j ich
finde ich nicht ich werde einfach vom
samstag
ich bin hier oben schon beim doppel
havanna auf dem album drauf so und darf
es vielleicht beim ersten versuch habe
ich es kommt schon vor hast du daran
ändern im kopf ja gut aber ich auch
länger ins kinn joana du hast und grün
wo ist denn ich bin nicht mehr oben auf
der seite los
mein lieblings greifen und oben am um
dann bist du ja du bist die belastung
grünen ja genau das bin ich den pullover
an das auto weil mein liebling von uns
treffen um auf staten island später also
neben dem trailerboot ist so sagt
ich habe alles ach dafür kommen einfach
wieder umbenannt ist ein schwert und
holzschwert kommen du dich wehren
während der runde um das tv event ab ins
grüne nahm er habe haben das dann sehr
auffällig
ich hab nur ein pfeil und bogen also auf
reisen schwert wäre noch schön wie du
bist nicht wo sie geblieben bin ich doch
nein du hast thompson teched europe
schwert ich bin so viel drauf warum ich
eben mein name noch mal geändert
es heißt wieder so wie aber ist es den
grün überhaupt habe ich und eben mein
name nochmal hingegen geändert ob warum
habe ich dann noch mal die pfeiltasten
nach oben gedrückt kein okay also warum
ist es nicht mehr ich bin in ostend und
ich denke mal warum das war der
schlüssel
ja verstehst du jetzt nicht etwas das
man vor dem spiel ein gibt zb flash
trades und im spieler einfach nur tee
hoch drückt aber man im spiel
das letzte was man prima technik josie
war dann im ändert man sagen ach der
insel oder wo seid ihr
ich wünsche mir unten im trailer peter
oster fertig bin ich den sinn ich bin
auch etwas untergehen schnelle peter
kommt da warte ich bin auch in reale
politik
denn peter du bist doch da ich bin
hinter dir da werde ich wieder hinein
tätern war als ich neun war hinein
lassen und auf den beruf
ich bin nicht ich werde wo seid ihr denn
aha da ohne snickers pictures kommst du
dir du wirst nicht würden die kraft
seiner stimme raus bitte bitte wirklich
laufwerke du wirst geführt ihr vater
schon drauf kommt der petra hatte verdi
das gar nichts stellt peter sich lieb
komm schnell okay
der fehler ist nicht an die insel da
gleich nicht hoch werden schreibt wächst
du hast mich leben ich bin nur zum test
kombinieren die tester so sieht eine
böse lache ich wusste das komplott der
böse ist weil er hat nämlich dann so
getan und dann kann
lauf lassen nein das ist die aufgabe
hier weiter töten
test.de mehr sprinten dann kann ich
nicht spritverbrauch geht's
so mal schauen er hat wahrscheinlich wie
eine krippe pfeile mehr
ja ich gebe es ein test damit die leute
glauben bei fernreisen schwert neuen
kontrakt ja du bist schön über preis
beträgt ok ok doch mal raus kommen lasse
was das spannende runde gegen den
schädel jubilarin von unten kommt zu
spät ist tot
nein ich bin einem kampf mit der diese
spät komm raus hier gold-chance
getroffen uhr lag bobby kotick wie
konntet ihr mich die leute treffen
ich hab dich nicht habt ihr alles
aufsaugen so bleibst du mich denn ich
hoffe du hast einfach nur ganz etwas
dahinter vor geguckt irgendwie ein ärmel
oder so ich habe also es gibt hier nun
mal kein ane port o rama.com mit
erleiden aber spiel ist spiel aber er
ist es um später armani egal 1130 kamera
auf jeden fall bis interessant er komme
bis am leben hat joss stone und yamada
gefallen
mich hat so ein typ nämlich immer weiter
nach vorne gedrängt und dabei bin ich
nachher gerade aus der welt gefallen auf
dem steg da oben egal ich fahre aber
auch ich hätte aber auch einen grünen
nahmen und das war bestimmt nicht mein
vater war es nicht mehr der typ da hat
modus an oder wie heißt das wenn man
steht und trotzdem alter ungespielt das
kreuz als aufgenommen werden ich war
immer
gestorben gerade okay da können wir
installiert lassen welcher 74 77
ja ok prime wie lange noch
ich nenne ich jetzt mal wieder um
gespielt kenne solche umtriebe nennt
peter art zu spät
ich stehe dem chef pah3 etr groß
schreiben mussten sonst als kind war ich
nämlich jetzt konkret achten geht gar
nicht doch es müsste gehen
da steht dann wenn du kannst mich wie in
wien dann glaube ich kann keinen namen
haben kommt läuft das land plötzlich in
unterhosen wo dann wurde in katar teil
jetzt weiß ich mal wie ich im laufe der
hass gar keins kinder hätten sie mal wie
viel kann fehlen zu 20.600 ungefähr 0
geht das schnell vorbei ja ich kann das
eigentlich wenn ich allein spielen
braucht dafür halbe stunde du hast du
das öfter ja da sind wir schon
aber ich will ebay tapas und solche
geschichten weil ich ja hier werde ich
auf leben und möchte ihre aufnahmen
begünstigen sage ich mal und ich will
euch nicht blockieren ich bin ja ein
sozialer mensch stehe wenn ich wirklich
von ihrer vielen dank dafür ich nehme
erst auf sie warten die players are
already you / trader 100 selber schuld
kannst du das auch immer voll
hundertprozentig ist um gespielt auch
trader weil sonst hätte er nicht gesagt
ja ich wirklich keinen trade up as
genommen natürlich ruhig zweitweise
fleisch immer schon etwas offensichtlich
hätte jetzt niemand
ihr habt euch etwas getan hast du zu
viele leute jobs eingebüßt haben ja wir
haben eben bei skype gechattet
miteinander haben wir fast abgemacht ja
ja ist also nur auf dich gehen werden
und ich jede nur verarschen werden ich
hab schon verstanden
ich will ein eisen schwert bitte ich
habe gesagt ich hab keins haben ein
holzschwert ich mit ich kann meinen
tester gehen euch das gerne unter beweis
stellt nämlich sand place ok einer von
euch brettert ziemlich hart auf der
tastatur um ja ich wollte da verfolgt
ach so jetzt freut warum das denn ich
weiss nicht okay leute mit dem falsch
ist allerdings gehört mit dem kobo wenn
wir zu dem cabo anlegt der wirt nebels
für die bahn legt ja ich sag euch nur
mal ich krieg heute ruhig mit einer
aufnahme hin
ich verstehe es nicht ich wind recht hat
und kriegt ich bin nach einem tot tot
weil nach hatte man endlich mal nicht
beobachtet nach einem kill bin nicht tot
damit alles okay und gestohlen
vielleicht heute
bin total um gespielt heißt
wahrscheinlich um gespielt ist liegt er
heißt gerade ungespielt ja nein ich habe
so ein pech nein das ist mal schön
gucken hier wer von euch beiden trainer
ist ja ich mache euch mal um gespielt
aber ich verrate pro server geklickt
auch sagen wie legal oder illegal heißt
wenn du einfach nur jetzt jemanden an
kriegst du tot bist das darf man nicht
machen
wo ist rom gespielt
ich bin tot nein
doch ja das gefühl kenn dich irgendwo
her warum warum
ja weil ich runter ich bin runter
gefragt wird verfolgt und das war mir zu
hektisch ja toll ich bin jetzt hier in
mein leben oder wie schöner leben joana
was machst du denn um gespielt ich war
tatsächlich gekillt doppel war auftreten
ich hasse euch einfach aber ich bin
ruhig auch ich bin schon lange tot ich
habe dir damit einen gefallen getan
getroffen sich schon lange raus bin
gefallen getan ich weiß nicht ob da
vorsicht gefahr von hin
überall lauern gefahren in dieser welt
ehrlich superman ist immer nicht so
gutem als film guckt wie superman ist
langweiliger film findet das auch sonja
ich find auch langweilig vor allem
spiele reisen schwert hatte es war ganz
amüsant wer wo bist du eigentlich gerade
ich habe super mann getötet
es gab auch jemand der so oft wie
superman worum geht es bei euch besteht
auch dann nicht klappt will ich nicht
verstehe es auch nicht das war
eigentlich total dorf nennen simon ich
hab gar nicht verstand was du laberst
aber ich auch nicht nach mir verspricht
alles ganz einfach nur super meldet ein
sehr gut besetzten st ach so ja zufällig
stand ich dann gerade auf sofas und
superman typen und habe dann immer so
gedacht kommt rezepte thema leute zu
viel in der welt es gibt zu viele leser
recht heftig hätte auch leichter sein
können
der letzte car verloren er hat natürlich
auch ich hab dann einfach mal geraten
und warum macht das spiel spaß risiko
risk no fun das ist mein motto ganz
genau
anna ist noch dieses match
okay da da da töten sie irgendwie in der
wegläuft
das ist aber alles leider meireles
soviel kammer damit könnte man
eigentlich jede runde immer erst
komplette den kompletten server einmal
ausschalten man hat immer noch genug so
einfach spaß mal eine runde
ich weiß ja ich wollte eigentlich mal
die kosten kamen bei mir aufnehmen
wollte sondern war es so dann ja und
dann wollte ich dir so aufnehme und da
habe ich gemerkt ich bin ja schon lange
drüber da habe ich mir gedacht was mache
ich denn mal dagegen ja da muss man
manchmal mal neben der außerdem
kommentiert der superman als superheld
und es gibt ja noch zum beispiel ein
superheld wie zum beispiel bett oder
spiderman sag ich mal
ja es gibt ja auch falls das ist ein
schwein das beider schwein genau genau
es bei der schweiz weiterhin ist ein
oder also ich meine so als super fix
kennt den hinter dir weiter schwein ist
nicht sehr gut oder
draußen richtig scheiße finde ich auch
ich mag blau ein wenig als meine
lieblingsstadt grün meine auch geil wir
schon mal zwei und und bariton braun
finde irgendwie auch ganz geil ich bin
blaue auch noch gut also grün und blau
im blau - ort nichts ankommt um einen
blau so richtig schön fröhliches so ein
richtig hell ist wendig und beim grünen
so einen schönen stellen ist wenn beim
blau so wie bei meinem kind so ein
bisschen belastet auch so herrsche du
hast gewonnen' cottbus gewonnen
glückwunsch dass ein erster fall das hat
mir spaß gemacht ich glaube ich ich häng
auch einzeln also noch mal auf einer
geht noch rein 333 l 1 12 sekunden bei
dem treffen den namen
geboren auf dem land um meine kühe keine
frau
doch ich vielleicht was ich kann so
lange ich nein und der die stop
arbeiterbildung okay leute genau weiß wo
ich noch durch die kisten
jetzt habe ich den ohrwurm werden
verdammt da na na na
und was konnten das normal ich weiß ist
in der farbe ach ja stimmt
dabei ist sowas anderem eigens räumen
und in einer sprache oder bombay wieso
ich habe schon mal alle sachen wie fehlt
noch ein bogen grafenstein schlägt den
bogen nicht mehr und im boden ist meine
lieblingsfarbe
ich tausche auch gegen eisen schwefel
passt also meine krisen container
tauschen
naja ich hab keinen boden bekommen
schade dann muss ich meinen trader
schnappen und hoffen dass er in bogen
hat so in 90 und geht's los macht euch
bereit die zeiten 432 effekt haben also
schwer diamant ich bin in los wenn ihr
nur ich bin ja ein kam wirklich echt
rüber ich bin wirklich ich gehe auch
geraten tester ihr seid ihr wieder trade
me heißt ich bin kein treffer der
gentest würde ich mir mache ich mache
ich bin ich bin wie heißen überhaupt
hier umbrella wenn ich am brett 93 ich
kann den namen gleich aussprechen ich
gebe immer englisch scheiße da einlasse
umbrella echt heiß hass und krieg in ein
college oder peters im test okay ich
glaube dir ja ich glaube ob es an meiner
hand ist ausgerutscht
april verschickt einmal aufschlag zurück
er wie deine hens konto auf das und
wirklich die besten defense kompetenzen
und ungespielt ist natürlich nicht beim
tester der gangelter ich habe eben so
viel passiert dass ich erst mal ein
bisschen verstecken musste ein leben wie
coach potato aufnahme couch potato 5000
hektar tester jetzt feld gekommen okay
ich hatte nur drei okay wer von euch
beiden gestorben ich gar nicht schlecht
aus ich hätte den kampf und irgendwie
die runde kann ich weiß nicht warum wie
ungespielt oft besserung runden schafft
ja wer sich mit dem falschen anlegt der
ba bu aber du hast - kammer brothers
trader
nein er war twitter er war kein trailer
sway notarzt nur so getan als ich war
wirklich in einem test jetzt gerade so
als ob du wirklich kein trader warst du
warst du noch prozentig trade
herumspielen natürlich freut mich das
kann auch nach gucken wer hier kann ich
kann englisch manchmal kann ich das man
kann nicht verfolgt mich doch und dann
geht es durch jetzt geht's in test
ich komme tester schreibt ich komme im
test eine tote zeit gewählt wurde war
dazu kein trader um gespielt sind ok -
kann man macht schaden
na gut mein leben freuen ich würde sagen
dann sehen wir uns in der nächsten folge
wieder wie immer wenn ihr es gut findet
könnt ihr bewerten und marius für falsch
doch mal richtig
doch für richtig wenn er schlecht fallen
könnte auch bewährt ja ihr könnt
bewerten ob es gut oder schlecht fand so
man könnte auch die map bewerten ich
glaube dort ist gesagt und kann ihr
könnt die map bewährten na ja wohl aber
ist halt normal ich auf jeden fall teuer
und dann haut rein und schutzmittel mit